uh water bottle was unfortunately thrown
at you
what did you feel in the crowd these two
nights did you feel that racism or
subtle racism that you had warned about
or had they pretty much kept it strictly
about basketball until
that incident as you were walking off
well like i said i've been in some
hostile environments where a lot of
things have been said to me a lot of
things been done to my teammates or i've
experienced
some type of subtle racism that i'm
referring to
you know where it's just underlying
throughout the game you know the things
that they're saying
it's not necessarily about talent or
gifts it's just more or less about moms
or
what you look like or they're calling
you out of your name and
like i said you know i joined this uh
this sport because i loved it and
inevitably you know you're going to have
opposing fans do things that
are going to help their team win you
know they love being involved
i don't want to take away that nature
it's just when you get when you feel
disrespected as a person
man or woman and someone calls you out
your name or does something like that
it doesn't make you feel good and then
when you react and we had times in
history where people are reacting
and gone in the crowd then we're wrong
and we need to we need to be civilized
and we need to keep our calm and we need
to keep our cool and it's reflected on
us
so um you know like i said just want to
keep it
uh upfront and truthful and it's just
unacceptable for that stuff to be
happening but we move on
so harry kind of piggybacking off my
weakest question
uh james just said before uh you joined
us that
he doesn't think that banning fans does
anything with this stuff because it
continues to happen and and he he'd like
to see the process change with all this
i'm curious if if you have thought on
that
yeah i think each one of us have our own
uh individual experiences but as a
you know as a black man playing in the
nba you know dealing with a lot of this
uh this stuff is it's fairly difficult
uh
you know because you never know when it
can happen uh or what's gonna happen
at the end of the game or before the
game uh so bannon fans
i get the objective uh but at the same
time it doesn't stop people from running
on the court i've had a situation where
in cleveland where people have run on
the court
uh you know i have situations so all so
often
uh throughout my career where you know
we don't really talk about it because we
want to be mentally tough we want to be
tough-minded
we don't want to be called soft or or
you know we're not man enough to deal
with
booze and you know fans never block my
shot so i'm not worried about
that type of physical uh you know type
of violence
it's just you know when they start doing
things that are just out of character
you know just getting belligerently
drunk
and um you know that's just what sports
is you mix
drunk people out in the crowd that are
cheering for the their team
you know you have some fans that are
there to watch the quality of the game
and then you have a mix of in between
and then you've got this inner mixing
and then
now we don't know who's who um but like
i said i just want to move on from this
man you know i've dealt with it as a
player here as a celtic
of different things and now being an
opponent again you know i just want to
move on so